how does an actor come up with a quote
unquote game plan for their career
maybe they're fresh from Minnesota
that's where I'm from yeah
um
uh I think you have to make a game plan
so how they come up with it you know
the basics are I need to get
first of all I need to have enough
funds where I can exist for a while I
need to get a day job I need to get an
agent I need to get a manager I need to
get a commercial agent because that's
easier to get and if I get a big
commercial that pays a lot of money so
you there's a short-term game plan
there's a long-term game plan I think
the short-term game plan is what I just
described people you know there's no
shortage of people
still coming here
still with the dream you know and and it
still is the center it's still the
center of the talent business
um Los Angeles New York as well I mean
New York is is similar in that way
uh and so I think the game plan is
originally uh the the initial game plan
is survival
get a job get a place to live get a car
get a you know and and call everyone you
know who knows anybody and see if I can
get a Toe Hold find a class find a
teacher find a coach whatever
and that ends up sometimes just being
the only game plan people have because
they can't
they can't move off from that there are
those who um
it's like I'm going to do another golf
analogy
like they're people who hit balls on the
driving range and there's people who
play golf
so people who are class rats who are
always in class have been in class for
10 years 12 years and I have some of
those and they but the ones I have work
they also work they're in class for a
while
they they're not in for a year or two
they come back for a year or two that's
different but the people who never
venture out of that bubble of class
they're hitting balls on the driving
range but they're not playing the game
of golf because the game of golf
requires oh there's a downhill lie oh
there's a water hazard there oh I'm in
the sand what do I do so it's different
so that the short-term plan is getting
all those things together
uh the survival stuff the long-term plan
is I'm a Believer and you have to make
the plan set the goal and and the goal
posts are often moving and fluid because
things change you know you either get
some people get very lucky there are
people I I know a lot of them
bless them got very lucky if something
happens and they just fall into it and
some people you know we all know
pardon me we all know really talented
actors brilliantly talented actors
who've never gotten any traction in
anything I know people like that
and it's hard it's hard for them
it's hard to see some of them give up
some of them don't and you know see
people of very modest mediocre talents
who who do very very well whether they
have a game plan or not I always think
you have to have it you have to create
it and have it and know that it's
changeable because only thing that's
constant in this endeavor is change the
amount of changes that I have seen
starting in my early early career to now
are just mind-blowing I mean
and at a certain point you go I don't
want any more change I wanted to stay
the way it is but it never does of
course so you have to adapt
and you have to adapt to what's new
what's fresh what people are interested
in what people are looking for what
people
what about you
will resonate in some way that you never
thought of before
so having the plan is important but also
knowing that the plan is very fluid and
changeable is also important because
most plans don't work most plans have to
be adapt you have to be adaptable and
and you know when I when I first bought
my house
I was working a lot and then all of a
sudden nothing
and I had this guy this great guy
next we had these next door neighbors
who were vaudevillians they were a
Vaudeville dance team oh wow phenomenal
just amazing people
and he had been an actor and he knew I
was an actor I didn't know him very well
and he knew I was an actor and he kind
of he
he came up to me I had been in the house
three four months and all of a sudden
working just dried up and I had a house
payment to make
and we were starting family and all that
stuff and he said and he was like a
really like almost like a Damon Runyan
character he was an old-timey New York
guy great guy
and he said how's it going kid
I said eh not so good
really that's all right it'll get better
it's like a straight car a new one
always comes by and uh he said you need
anything I said uh what do you mean you
need a touch do you need a little money
he hardly knew me wow I said no but no
no thank you but no he said well do you
ever need anything you come to me kid I
said that's on the level kid it was like
I'm talking to a Damon Runyan character
but I mean his was the guy who had been
in Show Business his entire life he was
in his 80s at that point and he started
as a kid and had been on Broadway had
been on The Ed Sullivan Show and have
been and so he knew that the long
trajectory of the career
he knew stuff that I didn't know I was
freaking out because I just bought a
house and stopped working
you know but so that that plan is is
it's as valuable as the paper it's
written on which is means it's you got
to have it but you have to also have to
understand how it moves and Shakes and
you've got to be adaptable and reinvent
reinvent reinvent reinvent that's what
it is
are there any don'ts you've mentioned a
lot of wonderful dues on the game plan
uh what about don'ts
stay away from this
be cautious of this
don't fall under the influence of a guru
because there's a lot of that which I
think is really hurtful and harmful
um
how do you know they're a guru though
well
when you get into what this is a good
question because many of the people who
are gurus are also quite brilliant
and they attract followers and
you know they're a guru when let's just
say in an acting class but they're it
happens in other areas too
when it becomes about pleasing the
teacher and not about your own personal
growth you're in the presence of a guru
you're in the presence of a narcissist
this is very common
very common I have seen it I've seen
people who've been involved with uh some
acting Studios that won't be named where
I've had to I won't use the word
deprogram but like I had one guy who was
a fantastic actor
and he was with this place for two years
and he said I don't even know how to act
anymore I've just I'm destroyed I don't
have I've lost whatever it is I had well
then you know you're in trouble right
that's that's not good so you have to
understand
you have to have a judgment is like
who's throwing the BS and who isn't and
what's the truth what's the MS the truth
which is Yiddish for truth you've got to
be after the emiss the truth and so
some people have bad judgment and they
don't know and they they they learn the
hard way or they get stung or they get
abused or whatever there's a lot of that
so I mean
it's really important to surround
yourself with people who understand what
you're about so don't fall under that
influence the other don'ts are like
don't sell yourself short
don't decide that you're only you're
only worth being at this level
um when I was talking to this young
woman yesterday who I'm trying to help
out with maybe finding a new manager
she's brilliant I mean she's I don't
throw that word around she's brilliant
and I said
you deserve that you deserve somebody
really good because you are outstanding
you're an uncommon talent and so and I
think she needed to hear that
I said do you know that about yourself
quiet said know that about yourself
that's important because you are that
way and you deserve somebody great and
so
you don't deserve you know there's a lot
of bottom feeders
who are agents managers whatever
and um
so know your worth
don't fall under the bad influence
and stay interested
stay interested I often ask people what
do you like what are you are you
watching something that interests you
who are your Heroes who do you like
who's great why don't you like that
person that's interesting what you know
to sort of develop a taste level that's
high
the great Ira Glass quote you know that
quote
it's about writers but it's really about
anybody who's doing anything creative he
based I'm going to paraphrase it but
it's a brilliant quote he basically says
that when you start doing something
creative
you have a taste level that's really
high that's what got you into it because
you you understand what's good but for
the longest time your work isn't as good
as what your taste level is and the only
way to get there is to just do lots and
lots of work to just continue to do work
to fail upward a little bit let's say so
that at some point
your level of talent and skill matches
your level of taste
so I can see things like I'm watching
The Morning Show right now which I think
is brilliant
and I go wow I mean I would love to be
in that and
I could play in that playground when I
did uh big little lies it was like I
hadn't worked for a little while because
I've been doing other things I've been
teaching writing books doing all that
stuff I went oh I've been invited back
to the grown-ups table that's what it
feels like and I was nervous
but as I was nervous for no reason it
was great it went great and it was fun
and it was I I felt
um validated in that way and so I think
it's understanding
what you're worth and a lot of that is
just who you know a lot of that is
who you are you know what you know
everybody's got some
bad stuff in their background that holds
them back an abusive parent or whatever
we've all got something
but it's understanding your story what's
your story who are you that worldview
exercise who are you what's your story
and do you deserve that if you don't
think you deserve it you're in the wrong
line of work you've got to believe that
and um
sometimes you get lucky and you and you
get you get to play with
people at a very very high level and
whenever I've been lucky enough to do
that
it's been just like
it should feel logical that you're there
oh this makes sense that I'm here with
Robert Duvall or Paul mazurski or
somebody else
that just makes sense because that's
what I've been working toward that's how
I see myself
so it's a lot of self actualization and
really and and positive thinking and um
my mother used to say I'm going to give
you a Dutch uncle talk and she would
tell me she would build me up she was a
little nuts my mother but she would
build me up in ways that were really
helpful and it's it's important to build
yourself up and have people around you
not to shine you on not to tell you how
great you are when you're not but to
really
share the dream that you have with you
as much as they can it's it's only going
to be your dream but to share it with
people like-minded people whether it's a
partner or a community